i invited her into my boudoir aka the
stabbin cabin
we disrobed one another i touched her on
her genitalia she
touched me on my manitalia and that's
when i hit
it sexually
of course
[Music]
sexually
oh
hi that wasn't expecting to see you all
undulating up here uh hi i just uh put
my jacket on the bed when i first came
to the party but uh i didn't realize
that the party made its way up here but
i'll get that now i will if you uh carol
i don't know if you're
in there somewhere but uh wherever you
are thank you for the invitation i
really enjoy myself i see you at work
tomorrow okay hey sir i think i see my
jacket i think i think your arm is in
the sleeve actually i'll grab that's not
my jacket and that's not your arm it's
not your arm white people are crazy
white people are crazy just looking for
a jacket sir okay yes very nice mustache
i've never seen one above the nose
that's interesting that's not your nose
okay sorry to uh disturb you sir just
looking for a jacket just the ordinary
man looking for a jacket you want to say
something to me sir are you okay
no thank you very much sir it tasted a
little bit like salty but but that's
okay it's tweed the jacket i'm talking
about and it's got leather patches on it
just oh maybe this is it thank you found
it and nope that's not it but
congratulations man you are doing great
with what god gave you nope don't look
at me in the eyes ma'am i don't want you
to steal my soul hi ladies nice to meet
you and sir yes i do see you too okay
yes
people are craving oh no i'm okay i
really am i'm uh already seeing a a
group of people and we're taking it
slowly we are taking it slowly it's a
church maybe some of y'all would be
interested in looking into that not mine
but one somewhere if that's okay thank
you ma'am for there it is i found it
found the jacket it's right here i'm
gonna pull it and i believe it might be
lodged somewhere within you i'm just
guessing because that is just a
little bit of resistance all right there
we go and you know what that is going to
be yours keep it thank you cover
yourself up carol if you're in there
i'll see you at the office tomorrow just
bring the bowl you can finish the egg
salad my god white people
[Music]
uh
now
it's pretty awesome
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
oh
dude how we gonna break the world record
if you can't keep it up
[Music]
oh damn
check that it out
what
is
that
i didn't know they made them like that
i don't even understand what i'm seeing
i would love to see what's under there i
am really curious about that
yeah
i mean i have no idea
well you know we uh we obviously have
some idea you know
[Laughter]
i don't
well you know it's uh you know it's a
coochie baby
yeah
or something
ah nah nah nah man it's this is
definitely her lady parts
or
maybe it's just more skin
no
it's a vagina yeah
or
maybe it's a little face under there
uh no
no it's it's definitely gonna be a
vagina why
but because she's a girl and girls have
vaginas man
what is that
what is a vagina
it's a woman's reproductive organ what
are you being serious right now
[Music]
thank you
that is all i require
there's aliens
there's an alien down here
i want to know what's going on with the
huge woman and i want to know what the
deal is with the red witch lady yes
yes you know what i'm saying
just straighten it out but i mean like
have you have you have you ever slept
with a black guy no
but i really want to me too
apparently it is like a whole other
thing than sleeping with white men oh no
no i i heard they're supposed to be like
way better at it or something yeah yeah
yeah i heard that too
i wonder if it's because they have like
like better rhythm
you know
right because they're really good
dancers i mean apparently they have like
bigger
oh way bigger penises right
i guess that's because of africa
yeah like i feel like they're just
they're like really with you in the
moment like if they're gonna be with you
they're in the here and now exactly
exactly
because they know that they basically
have no future think about it so sad
think about it
[Laughter]
i do feel like they treat their women
with just like a little bit more
compassion yeah like respect and stuff
oh
because their dads were never around oh
right
and they also have a lot of time on
their hands because even if they have
kids they never go visit them oh please
totally baby daddy that's a thing oh
that's in the dictionary now because of
black people see
seriously
apparently black guys just know how to
please white women right just like way
more than white men oh well it's
probably in their blood
because they're used to pleasing their
white masters
yeah law of the jungle right totally i
am so desperate to find out for myself
me too all right
okay
um
i'm gonna go to the bathroom okay
and i swear to you if there's a black
guy back there i'm gonna blow it
get it
so unrelated i now have to go to the
bathroom uh because i've been drinking
coffee all day
so
i will be back in a little while well
you know what let me go first i'll be
about 30 seconds
oh ow i hit my penis there
i'm sorry i don't have any money sir
okay
what up homies welcome to cuddle linkage
class i'm chaboose michaels i'm t-ray
tombstone and we're here to teach y'all
how to go down home [__] right now
[__] ain't being satisfied so check
it quick [__] on that clitoris so
damn hard [__] don't like that
nonsense that's like putting the tip
your penis in the vacuum y'all need to
chill on the clitoris go around that
business that's like a button made of a
million penis toss now every [__] like
her cunniling is a little bit different
vaginas are like snowflakes no flex is
different learn yo [__] snowflakes
ask your [__] what she wants then do
what she says some [__] like it in a
circle some [__] like it up and down
somebody just like your heart [__]
like it's solved communicate with your
[__] make your alphabet with your
tongue a b
c d let me see grab your hair like
you're gonna pull your damn head off
stick with that letter we're talking
about
vaginas deserve respect you don't want
someone slapping around your little
homie
you with the hat yo how you like your
bj's damn dog all the time
shut the [__] up that's cause penises is
easy and vaginas is hard they're
confusing
imagine there's an explosion at the
envelope factory flaps everywhere a
world of flash you need to lick your way
out the factory but every bitch's flaps
is different earn your [__]
particular flaps perhaps be crazy
every flap need to be listened to and
then you will get out of the factory
alive stay down there plan your
breathing like you're swimming you gotta
be talking about stroke stroke breathe
stroke stroke breathe
all right let's take a five minute break
when we come back we're gonna talk about
warming your [__] up before you get
busy and that'll last for more than two
damn minutes take a peach and practice
practice on a piece take a picture
practice wrap this on take a picture
oh
i think it's gonna work
30 down
3 billion to go
[Laughter]
it's a weird one
nothing out of place
no murder weapon and no motive there's
uh just a couple lying dead in their bed
the proof is always out there detectives
you just have to know where to find the
pudding excuse me sir you can't be here
this is a crime scene
it's okay
he's the greatest sex crime investigator
in history
if it isn't detective chuck vaughn
detective sally ferguson oh you could
use a genius right now tom samwell
what have we got samwell well uh vomit
we've got ourselves a hard case here
all we've got is two bodies both dead
naked one man one woman
in the bed two scented candles by the
nightstand how did you
no sign of forced entry
he loved the way they smelled
he wanted to cross the threshold the way
they had on their wedding day
you dirty dog
he would have experienced that pleasure
right here
anniversary a couple was together for a
while wanted to spice things up
check the date on the photograph
vaughn's right
today was their 15th wedding anniversary
this is huge
and
what the was that you just pulled your
dick out and started jerking off at the
crime scene samwell
he's the best there is by putting
himself in the perpetrator's mindset
he's able to solve crimes that involve
sex bag this up
some call it a blessing
it's more like a curse is that what it
feels like
threesome
you wanted to see them didn't you you
wanted to watch
25 feet from the bedroom
across from the kitchen
[Music]
you didn't want to see their flesh yet
did you
no
he stood
right here
[Laughter]
[Music]
role play gone wrong check the logs
we've got a bloody fire poker we've got
our murder weapon
um
why do your revelations require
masturbation
why do kittens require milk no not the
same thing hey hey he's the most
brilliant goddamn detective i know put
your ego aside and give vaughn his space
my ego we've got captain pudpuller
flinging his fluids all over the crime
scene wait
he knew them
they
they were close so close
too close he
he
i think he knew
the house
why
what did you want you sick bastard
you wanted to see
[Music]
what he saw every day
only closer
closer
[Music]
he was close to home
all right let's go get him go go
vaughn
that was amazing i'm sorry
that i doubted you
your methods are unorthodox but
i cannot argue with your results
no hard feelings uh no no not gonna do
that
i wake up next to this guy and
as usual i don't even know his name
i'm trying to get dressed quickly and
get out of there before he wakes up but
i can't find my underwear
i look everywhere but
i just can't find them
and then it hits me
i had left them at another guy's
apartment earlier that night
and that's when i knew i had a problem
[Applause]
thanks for sharing skype
well i noticed a lot of new faces this
evening
and i'm so glad you all came
and i want you to know
that this is a safe place to share
so if you want to tell us your story
there'll be no judgment
sure i'll go
hi y'all
name's wendell
and
i am
in fact
a sexual addict
i wouldn't know
and what brings you here wendell
well
you know my life
sexually speaking
it's crazy and i just want to find
one
single solitary person
to spend the rest of my life with just
one
just one
so do you feel like your addiction is
too much to handle right now duh
i mean it's been crazy y'all
with me the nastier the better
i'm a dirty dog
try everything all the fixins
tantric
much like sting
all the bells and whistles you name it
i've dunced it
and when would you say you hit rock
bottom wendell when it got slippery
outside my shower on the floor outside
my shower
oh
i hit rock bottom sexually
well probably last night last night do
you think that you could tell us what
happened wendell
yeah let's see uh it's just like any
other night i had ordered a large pie
pepperoni pineapple cheesy crust cheesy
bread on the side
i cut to
30 min later
pizza parlor sent over a delicious
lady delivery person
body 10
face 10
that's my weakness
so i invited her inside
opened up the box it was hot
devoured the first slice lickety-split
crust first
second slice didn't stand a chance
ate the tip of that [__] first washed
it down with a pop
then i got nasty with the cheesy bread
my heart started pounding harder than
usual cursed lunch
cursed slunk
moved on to the third slice
what about the girl what girl
oh the girl yeah she was there too
i invited her into my boudoir aka the
stabbin cabin
we disrobed one another i touched her on
her genitalia she
touched me on my manitalia and that's
when i hit it
sexually
of course
upstairs downstairs all around the town
stairs as you do
and uh
by then it
was just another night and i mean
oil everywhere and
sauce
all over me
oh yeah that's my word for
ejaculate
anywho i'm so uh distraught because i
feel vulnerable and i don't know i just
feel like anyone
could take advantage of me right now and
knee
won
okay let's see what the blondes have to
say first
well thank you wendell um thank you for
sharing it's actually our time today
[Applause]
[Music]
oh